when the Republican presidential
candidates gather to debate in Colorado
they're sure to be asked about that
state's phenomenally successful
experiment and legalizing marijuana
Republicans say they love states rights
but they almost all hate recreational
pot I say it's bad medical marijuana is
another thing but I think it's bad and I
feel strongly about that that tension
has led to some pretty wild and stupid
rhetoric here are the four weak
arguments Republicans have made against
legal pot number one marijuana is not
booze pot has long been compared to
alcohol in the legalization effort but
as Carly Fiorina reminds us they're not
equal this is a very complex chemical
substance and when we tell young people
is just like drinking a beer we're not
telling them the truth yes pot is not
beer indeed the government's own facts
show that marijuana can actually be
safer than alcohol according to the
Center for Disease Control 88,000 people
die each year from alcohol use that's
one in 10 adults no such category exists
for marijuana other studies have shown
that drinkers are more likely than
stoners to develop substance abuse
issues which adds more cost to our semi
socialized health care system plus
there's that whole hangover thing number
two the drug war is a fail so let's keep
doing it I think quite frankly the war
on drugs has been a failure if you were
president would you return the federal
prosecutions in the states like Colorado
Washington State yes
the New Jersey Governor is not alone on
this one when asked by Glenn Beck about
legalization ben Carson had this to say
do you continue the war on drugs
absolutely you do i intensified since
the early 1970s the United States has
spent over a trillion dollars on the war
on drugs and what have we gotten for our
money prisons that are so overcrowded
that judges are letting violent
criminals go free to make room for drug
offenders coming in at number three we
don't know enough about marijuana yet
when I had cancer my doctor asked me if
I had an interest in medicinal marijuana
I did not and he said good numerous
medical studies have shown marijuana to
be enormous ly beneficial to cancer
patients by reducing symptoms and the
paint
side effects of chemotherapy in fact pot
has even been shown to kill some types
of cancer cells in several lab tests and
it's also shown promising results and
treating children with epilepsy and then
there's Marco Rubio I've said that I'm
open to medicinal uses of anything in
particular marijuana and if in fact it
goes through the FDA process you know
because the FDA has a long record of
getting it right finally there's the if
we allow legal marijuana then Kim Davis
shouldn't have to grant gay marriages
argument wait what how come it is that
liberals are okay with not keeping the
federal law when it comes to the
marijuana laws and it's okay for the
states to ignore it but if it comes to a
county clerk in Kentucky who doesn't
believe that she can abide by a federal
court ruling not even a law then she
goes to jail how could be maybe
comparing apples to oranges here but the
clear difference is that one example
takes away people's rights while the
other gives them more choice and freedom
and more freedom is always a good thing
right Republicans